hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
ein ganz klassisches grundrezept für
leckere waffeln die ich noch mit zimt
und vanille verfeinert habe später habe
ich die leckeren waffeln allerdings noch
aufgepeppt mit süßigkeiten nutella und
kirsch spritze
jetzt zeige ich euch zuallererst die
zutaten für den teig wir benötigen
weiche butter mehl lauwarme milch zimmer
war maya eine prise salz zucker
backpulver und zum verfeinern wenn ihr
mögt zimt und vanille zucker oder mandel
extrakt und ich habe mich für das
extrakt entschieden nun nehmt ihr eure
mutter zusammen mit dem zucker in euro
schlüssel und mixt das ganze mit dem
handmixer circa ein bis zwei minuten
lang geschmeidig
an der stelle gebe ich meine prise salz
noch mit dazu denn das salz hebt noch
einmal den süßen geschmack und
anschließend gebe ich die eier mit dazu
wir werden jetzt gut unter gemixt und
sobald sich die butter mit den eiern
verbunden hat geben wir die milch mit
dazu
wer kein zimt fan ist können hier auch
ganz einfach weglassen
andersrum könnt ihr aber auch statt dass
man in extrakt gerne eine abgeriebene
zitronenschale mit reingeben etwas
zitronensaft und dann habt ihr leckere
zitronen waffe
jetzt muss nur noch das mehl und das
backpulver hineingelegt werden
ich liebe das immer ganz gerne damit
keine klümpchen entstehen dann rühre ich
das noch mal ganz schnell unter und dann
ist der teig auch schon fertig
um das waffeleisen vorzubereiten müssen
das noch einen fetten entweder mit back
trend spray das nehme ich sonst immer
ganz gerne
aber weil das viele nicht da haben
könnte ich hier natürlich auch ganz
einfach mutter verwenden das waffeleisen
macht ihr am besten nicht ganz so heiß
ich habe hier stufe 3 von 5 genommen und
dann gebe ich eine kelle von dem
waffelteig hinein
der teig muss auch nicht komplett das
waffeleisen ausfüllen denn der verteilt
sich automatisch sobald ihr den deckel
drauf gibt eine waffe dauert bei mir ca
ein bis eineinhalb minuten dann nehme
ich sie auch schon raus und legt sie auf
einem gitter
und so packt ihr nun eine waffe nach der
anderen aus am ende habe ich neun stück
erhalten es kommt natürlich immer darauf
an die große waffeleisen ist mein
verleger ich euch gerne mal unten in die
infobox
zwischendurch solltet ihr das
waffeleisen auch immer mal wieder nach
fetten
gerne könnt ihr eure noch warme waffeln
auch so schon genießen das schmecken
unglaublich lecker aber ich wollte sie
gerne noch aufpeppen und bereitet dafür
zuallererst den kirsch kompott dafür
benötigen die sauerkirschen speisestärke
und vanillezucker den saft der
sauerkirschen habe ich gut abtropfen
lassen und gebe den jetzt in meinem kopf
zusammen mit der speisestärke und dem
zucker
jetzt wird alles gut und klümpchen frei
verrührt der herd der bleibt in der
stelle noch aus den schalte ich erst an
sobald das ganze gut verrührt wurde
sobald der saft dann aufgekocht ist seht
ihr dass er auch ein bisschen dunkler
wird und einlegt und dann gebe ich die
kirchen mit dazu und unser kirsch
kompott ist fertig
das gebe ich jetzt erstmal an die seite
und zeigt euch in der zwischenzeit was
ich schönes eingekauft habe um einen an
der waffel fertigzustellen
ihr könnt auch gerne etwas obst dazu
nehmen ich habe mich hier für bananen
entschieden und außerdem brauchen wir
nutella einmal um die waffe zu
bestreichen und um den teller zu
beschriften und mit der beschriftung des
tellers beginnen wir auch damit die
schon mal vorbereitet sind und dafür
fühlt ihr euch etwas montella in einen
spritzbeutel und schneidet vorne die
spitze ab anschließend könnt ihr wie mit
einem stift euren namen auf den teller
schreiben
nun kommt der absolut spaßige teil und
dann nehmen wir uns eine waffel und
bestreichen die mit nutella ihr könntet
ihr an der stelle auch marmelade nehmen
oder jeden anderen aufstrich den die
gerne mögen diese waffel ist jetzt die
vom hamza er hat sich für yogurette und
raffaello entschieden und am besten
schneidet ihr die auch schon mal zurecht
damit die die waffe später auch
einigermaßen zu kriegt dazu wollte er
noch ganz gerne ein paar kokosflocken
und bananenscheiben
jetzt klappen wir das hintere drittel
der waffe um so dass wir den inhalt noch
sehen können
ich nehme dann eine winkel palette zu
hilfe um die waffel auf meinen teller zu
transportieren
dann gebe ich da noch großzügig
puderzucker drauf und weiße kuvertüre
die waffe sieht er schon mal ganz gut
aus aber jetzt zeige ich euch meine
variante hierfür habe ich mich auch für
nutella und bananen entschieden und gäbe
dann kinderbonus und schoko box darauf
an der stelle gebe ich schon puderzucker
drauf für die optik und klappe die waffe
dann erst um und anschließend nehme ich
mir wieder meine winkel palette zu hilfe
und transportiert die waffel auf meinen
teller
und jetzt kommt unser highlight nämlich
das warme kirsch kompott das gebe ich
jetzt noch großzügig auf die waffe und
lasse das richtig schön an den seiten
herunter fließen
für ein richtig hübsches finish gebe ich
jetzt noch großzügig puderzucker auf den
gesamten teller und dann ist meine waffe
auch schon fast fertig
was auf beiden teller nämlich nicht
fehlen darf ist frisch aufgeschlagene
sahne und dieses schöne muster bekommt
ihr übrigens mit der raschen ball piping
tülle hin ich verlinke sie euch gerne
mal in die infobox und jetzt würde mich
noch interessieren welche waffe würde
die hessen die von ramsauer die von mir
schreibt es mir gerne mal in die
kommentare
hi leute ich bin der hansa und ich habe
noch nie was gewonnen
also ich würde mich echt darüber freuen
wenn du für mich abgestimmt danke ok
bleibt man bitteschön hinter der kamera
haben sie also ich freue mich wenn ihr
den kanal abonniert damit ihr nichts
mehr verpasst und freue mich wenn ihr
beim nächsten mal wieder einschaltet